you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
who's the blame for soaring gas prices
the british public says profiteering
energy companies the russian government
and growing global demand
climate change threatens the future of
the winter olympics as rising
temperatures create a greater need for
artificial snow
and an endangered monkey and a large
headed frog are amongst
224 new species discovered in southeast
asia
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
energy companies focused on their
profits the russian government and
growing global demand of what the
british public feel is causing gas
prices to soar
a survey by the energy and climate
intelligence unit think tank provided
exclusively to sky news
also finds that the vast majority of the
public do not support removing green
levees from energy bills to help
consumers cope with rocketing fuel
prices
well the survey found that more than a
third of the public blame energy company
profiteering for gas price rises nearly
a third thought the russian government
reducing gas supplies to europe was the
key driver
and 28 blamed increasing global demand
well our correspondent hannah thomas
peter joins us now from southwest london
and hannah so interesting to see who the
public blames for rising energy public
prices but does this survey give us any
insight in what they'd like done about
it
some very clear insight actually into
what the british public think should be
done and shouldn't be done
interesting that only 13 percent
think that removing green levees from
energy bills is the right answer
although of course there is lots of
support for removing vat from energy
bills uh half of those questions said
that the best option was to decrease
reliance on gas by using more renewable
energy and better insulating homes and
there was this is really interesting
this bit there was a broad support for
the uk's net zero target
but nearly a third of people
agreed with the statement we can't
afford to implement policies intended to
address climate change
now that is the thing that's going to
catch the eye of those tasks with
delivering net zero it's the thing
one of the many things that keeps them
up at night because
although poll after poll has showed that
there's really solid public support up
and down the country for tackling
climate change and getting to net zero
there is also now
growing concern amidst a cost of living
crisis that people aren't going to be
able to find the money they need to
invest in going green because
the government
can't possibly cover the cost for
everybody in the coming 10 to 15 years
it might have to raise taxes might have
to reduce public spending and yes there
is at this point point a tacit
acknowledgement that consumers are going
to have to go into their own pockets and
that delicate mix is going to be have to
it's going to have to be executed really
excellently to keep the public with the
government keep that support coming for
net zero targets politicians trying
really really hard to make sure that
that support doesn't evaporate
hannah thanks very much
now climate change is threatening the
future of the winter olympics and other
sporting events as rising temperatures
create a greater need for artificial
snow the beijing olympics which get
going next week will be the first winter
games to use almost 100
fake snow but experts warn this can be
bad for the environment as well as the
competitors our sports correspondent tom
parmenter has more
this is the bobsleigh run at bath
university and it's how you train for
snow sports and winter sports when you
don't have ice and snow because you
don't hear in somerset but
the winter games is going to be quite
unusual because it will be the first
winter olympics where they're relying on
100
artificial snow and that has raised lots
of questions from athletes who are
concerned about the higher ice content
that you find in artificial snow versus
natural snow and therefore is it as safe
and as forgivable to fall on and there
are also many questions about
sustainability of the winter olympics
when the climate is changing
official snow can be bad for the
environment for a number of reasons from
an energy standpoint it's enormously
energy intensive to produce snow
there's also the water question so for
beijing 49 million gallons of water are
being used to produce the snow and
that's assuming it goes well so if
anything goes wrong or it gets a little
warm it's going to be more than that and
then there's the question of additives
as well right so when you are making
artificial snow typically in order to
keep it in good condition you have to
add certain chemical additives and those
are being introduced to the biome that's
not expecting that kind of pesticide
essentially or herbicide
type product into the system climate
change we've seen it already
erode the season length so we've lost
about 30 days on both sides of the
atlantic since the 70s in the winter
season and moving forward we are
expecting to lose more days of snow in
their defense the organisers of these
games point out that they are reusing
some of the venues from the summer
olympics that the chinese capital hosted
back in 2008 and of course there are the
usual offsetting measures carbon
limiting measures to try to make sure
that the footprint of the games is as
small as it can be so electric and
hydrogen vehicles are just one of the
very common themes that we now see at
major sporting events but more long-term
there are far-reaching questions for
winter sports as to the threat that they
face from a changing climate and how the
winter games and other events adapt to
try to make sure that they grow
participation which is one of their core
objectives but also remain sustainable
now some of the day's other climate news
and thailand's navy is working to clean
up as much as 160 thousand litres of oil
that leaked from pipeline the spill is
near an industrial area in the gulf of
thailand but authorities have warned
that if the slick isn't contained oil
could reach beaches by friday
star petroleum said the leak began at
around 9 00 pm local time on tuesday and
was stopped shortly after midnight
at least 100 000 unnecessary ghost
flights could be flown across europe in
order for airlines to keep their takeoff
and landing runway rights according to
analysis by greenpeace empty planes
could generate up to 2.1 million tons of
greenhouse gas emissions
due to the pandemic the european
commission had cut the threshold for
airlines to keep their slots from 80 to
25
in december that was up to 50 and will
rise to 64 in march
67 of secondary school teachers say
climate change is not taught in a
meaningful and relevant way that will
prepare students for the effects of the
climate emergency ahead of mps voting on
the climate education bill the teach the
future campaign is calling on the
government for integrated mandatory and
assessed climate education across all
subjects in the school curriculum rather
than just being limited to science and
geography
briana has pledged more than 10 million
pounds to fight climate justice the
singer who's from barbados is making the
donation to 18 climate justice
organizations working in seven caribbean
nations and the united states rihanna
said the grants will focus on groups
with female lgbt and black or indigenous
leaders due to their communities being
disproportionately affected by climate
change
and a big-headed frog and a popa langer
monkey are among 224 new animal and
plant species that have been discovered
in southeast asia the wwf said a total
of 155 plants 16 fish species
17 amphibians 35 reptiles and one mammal
have been found in the great mekong
region which spans cambodia lao myanmar
thailand and vietnam
bentley has released details of its 2.5
billion pound sustainability program
over the next 10 years they include the
luxury car makers first ever
battery-powered vehicle which it says
will be brought to market in 2025. the
company aims to become carbon neutral by
2030 making exclusively electric cars
chairman and chief executive adrian
hallmark told me he's confident the
country's infrastructure will adapt
it's true that others have been to the
ev market before us but if we operate in
the luxury segment we build big cars and
the challenge for us has been when does
the battery technology to support the
kind of cars that we offer today and
that we want to build for the future and
if you look at the development of
battery technology between 25 and 30 in
particular
we believe now the inflection point has
arrived the battery power density is
getting to where it needs to be for long
distance and for high performance
vehicles and that's what we do for
regular car drivers many of them just
find electric cars too expensive are
electric cars always going to be the
preserve of the rich do you think they
are more expensive but that will change
i think if we look at the developments
over the past 10 years or last five
years you know we're part of the
volkswagen group and if we look at the
id3 id4 strategy and what's coming in
the next phase
all of the industry is fully dedicated
to drive down the cost of batteries and
to get to close to parity of the cost of
ownership between an electric and a
non-electric car and let's face it even
though the initial acquisition price of
an electric vehicle is higher than an
equivalent combustion engine vehicle
to fill up an electric vehicle at home
in a six-hour charge overnight when
you're not using the car anyway
is 10 to 20 pounds depending upon the
size of the car
whereas to fill the same vehicle up with
fuel would be 60 to 100 pounds so if you
multiply that over the life of the
vehicle there is a break-even point so
the total picture works and most people
will lease or finance cars anyway so we
think the combination of reduced costs
together with normal financial models
and the the benefits of lower cost of
running uh will within the next five to
ten years at
the very latest get to parity with
today's combustion engine vehicles but
do you think that the government could
do more to make evs more affordable it's
very difficult because the government
has lots of priorities and we as an
industry have to be competitive and
create compelling offers for our
customers and yet a lot of prospective
buyers are really concerned that that
charging infrastructure is just still
way too patchy is it really up to
scratch
today no um
but within the rate in which it's
improving
and well if we break it down first of
all a lot of people charge the car at
home they rarely use them on the move
um and so for those people that have
ability to charge from home it's already
a practical alternative as long as
you're not doing regular 1000 mile trips
which very few people are
so the infrastructure between cities is
already developing and growing but over
the next five years my point is i'm
confident that we'll grow
do so coming up here on the daily
climate show i'll be joined by the
director and founder of uplift tessa
khan and policy director at the grantham
research institute on climate change and
the environment bob ward and we'll be
asking how best to teach children about
climate change and what's the future for
the winter olympics
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with the
director and founder of uplift tessa
khan and policy director at the grantham
research institute on climate change and
the environment bob ward so good evening
to both of you
so as keen viewers of our show will
appreciate climate change is a huge
subject science biodiversity economics
politics i could go on so how can you
design a curriculum that brings all
those different elements into the
education system without it being
overwhelming and bob 67 of uh secondary
school teachers say that climate change
is not taught in a meaningful and
relevant way that will prepare students
for the effects of the climate emergency
so how do you think that climate change
should be taught should there be lessons
just focusing on climate change or do
you think it should be infused into all
the different subjects across the
curriculum
well climate change is currently in this
national curriculum for schools in
science lessons when they learn the
basics of how the climate works and how
man's affecting climate and then also in
geography where they learn about things
that lead to climate change such as the
energy system and and how we can tackle
it so it's already embedded in the
national curriculum but the question is
is it um should it be included in other
lessons and there are ways of course in
which you can include climate change say
in english by asking pupils to write
essays
about uh climate change their own
experience for instance there's a lot of
books around now uh both
non-fiction and fiction about climate
change that you can have students
listening to you could design
mathematics problems that use climate
examples so there are ways of embedding
it but the most important thing is if
you're going to add further things into
the national curriculum most teachers
say well we already have a lot in there
what would we take out and that would be
very very difficult yeah that is a
problem isn't it tessa that there's so
much that children do need to learn
about
do you try and
inject climate change into english
lessons as bob suggests or into politics
lessons into
lessons about business it covers so many
different areas doesn't it what's your
answer
yeah that's right anna and i think you
know as we've heard from the stories on
your program tonight there is no aspect
of our life that you know will not be
touched by climate change so it makes
sense to integrate it across a range of
subjects and i you know i have to say i
really admire the
future campaign and the leadership that
you know once again young people in the
uk are showing on the issue of how to
address the climate crisis how to
prepare for it um but i think you know
ultimately
the hard truth of the matter is that by
the time those young people are in
positions of real power a real political
power where they can make the decisions
that need to be made um to keep
you know climate change to a safe level
you know
that that moment will have passed and
what we need are the adults in the room
today the people who are in power our
governments the political decision
makers to actually do everything that
they can to keep warming to below that
critical threshold of 1.5 degrees and
not leave it to young people to continue
to shoulder the responsibility for this
crisis and we just haven't seen that you
know from this government which is
distracted by crises of its own making
when
when we are dealing with a climate
emergency and when the solutions to that
namely reducing greenhouse gas emissions
getting off fossil fuels are so clear
yeah and and we could go into a whole
different conversation couldn't we about
that and the government's saying we've
got some of the best targets in the
world as far as emissions are concerned
but let's stick to education if we can
and bob i mean how do you teach climate
change without scaring children
well that's an important question you
want uh people to be empowered by the
knowledge and
they play a very important role at the
moment i know that in many families it
is the children and and what they're
learning not just in school lessons but
also learning themselves
they are the drivers of understanding in
in families at the moment and getting
changes in their parents but one of the
most powerful lobbies i know in the
world are young um female students who
are in particular targeting their
fathers or mothers who are in senior
positions in business and telling them
you have to take this seriously so i
think they're very it's very very
important but people need to understand
that this is this is a living subject
and people need to feel empowered to do
they want to know what to do
and very quick thought from you tessa on
this this issue of you know some of the
pictures we see on our screen some of
the projections and the warnings are
quite scary
we have to handle the subject very
delicately don't we with younger people
well i mean anna you know again the fact
is that as was demonstrated by a study
that was published in the lancet late
last year what is really driving anxiety
among young people is not the facts of
climate change per se it's the sense of
betrayal that they feel that governments
aren't taking the action that's needed
even though governments have
acknowledged that we are in a climate
emergency so if we really care about the
mental health of young people we need to
focus on acting and you know acting at
the scale and pace that's required not
you know not running away from the
problem okay let's move on to our next
subject shall we and uh the winter games
in china will rely entirely on
artificial snow and a study this week
showed that only one of the last 21
winter olympics venues that sapporo in
japan will be suitable to host the event
in future if global warming continues on
its current trends
so how can winter games adapt to a
changing climate
tessa rising temperatures then are going
to have a real impact on host cities of
the
olympic games the winter games in future
but
how much does it matter i mean if you
can
import snow or rely on artificial snow
is that the end of the world
well i think you know this research is
just another way of illustrating this
problem which you know as i said is that
there is no aspect of our lives that
won't be touched by climate change if we
don't get it under control and i think
that research demonstrates that on our
current trajectory you know there won't
be anywhere in the world that can
actually host the winter olympics and
provide safe sustainable conditions for
athletes but you know that's as i said
one example we also in the uk already
know that communities here are
experiencing
more you know increased intense flooding
for example also a result of climate
change and we can't adapt our way out of
these impacts if we are
reaching you know levels of climate
change that are dangerous which is the
trajectory that we're on now we've got
to just address the root cause of the
problem which is greenhouse gas
emissions which are overwhelmingly being
driven by fossil fuels and you know the
uk is the second largest oil and gas
producer in europe we've got to move
away from those fossil fuels if we're
going to ensure that we not only have a
winter olympics but that we have a
livable climate more broadly
bob do you think that future sporting
events like this are under threat do you
think that skiing is under threat given
global warming and the beijing relying
almost entirely on artificial snow it's
going to use an estimated 49 million
gallons of water i mean what are the
implications in the future
well the difficult thing is that most of
the resorts and places where people
currently go for uh winter sports they
are relatively low levels and they're
they're there because they want to be
connected to make it easy for people to
arrive so the only way you're really
going to be able to find um
ways of doing winter sports with natural
snow is to move into places that are
less accessible higher up mountain
ranges further into the mountain ranges
but that would be a huge undertaking you
can't build a you know a ski resort and
uh winter sports venues so easily but
that's where we might go we have to go
move up in the mountain ranges and of
course that then increases the risk of
things like
altitudes dealing with the effects of
altitude so there's no quick fix this is
just another example as tesla's saying
of the long-term consequences of the
fact that the earth is warming and uh we
have to deal with the consequences yeah
and tessa does news like this when
you're talking about the winter games
does it actually get the message across
to people in a way that perhaps some
other warnings on climate change don't
when they can see a warning about the
future of the olympics
yeah i think it does in so far as you
know the olympics of a kind of universal
cultural event that no matter where you
live
um you've heard about you probably tune
into and the thought that after so many
decades um it may simply cease to exist
because we haven't gotten the climate
crisis under control is you know i think
yeah a way of making that quite tangible
but it is again only the tip of the you
know proverbial iceberg in terms of the
huge impact that the climate crisis is
going to cause if we don't get serious
about addressing its root causes okay
well we must leave it there but tessa
khan bob ward always interesting to get
your take on things thanks very much
indeed for tonight
and just to let you know that tomorrow
i'll be joined by climate researcher in
the application of artificial
intelligence to climate change and
founder of climate in color joycelyn
london and senior associate at the
energy and climate intelligence unit
richard black but for now that's it
thanks for watching i'll see you next
time
[Music]